Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and uh,
this is a very special edition of
the Monday morning podcast. You know,
every once in a while here on the podcast
rather than listening to my psycho
ramblings in my jam jams is I lay
on my bed every once in a while. A,
I'll have a guest on
of highest steam and a,
this episode is of no a exception. This
is a man I've done a lot of radio with,
but I've never had as a guest.
Please welcome the one, the only,
the legendary from New Jersey.
Mr Jimmy Norton. Thank you bill.
What's going on?
It's funny. It's like, do I know you're
such a solo guy when you do your podcast?
I almost felt like when I texted
you to do it, I almost felt like I,
you were the hardest one for me to text.
I know you longer than I know
any of them. Right? And it was,
you are the hardest one because I'm like,
Bill does it by himself.
I didn't want to put them on the spot.
But you said you've had some guests.
No, no. I've had. Great.
To add Jay more, I've had,
I've had Dave character, I've had
a, Michael Rapaport was great.
Just the whole sports thing. That guy's
like a total like hoop head and I'll,
yeah,
fuck Boston and all that.
So we had a great going back and forth
and of course he trusts me for the giants
beat in the Patriots.
So I tried to get guests then I'm
friends with because I'm not the greatest
interviewer and uh, so
I definitely, you know,
someone that had done a bunch
of radio with now watch,
are we feeling the tension
that it's all going to go off
the rail cell?
It's funny,
it's one of those days off whenever
you're with a friend or whoever you're
interviewing or talking to somebody that
you know as well as we know each other,
it's all you want to feel
self conscious. Like, oh no,
they're going to think I'm putting on my
performer hat or my interviewer hat or
my radio guy. It's like, oh Jim,
tell us how did you get your start?
Oh No.
And that's what comedy podcasts into
every comic has in Collin won't do them.
He's like, I'm sick and tired of talking
about to go fucking process. You know,
he didn't want to hear what the
process and he's right. I'm actually,
I'm out of here
stories.
I kind of like tapered back on doing other
podcasts not cause I don't like other
podcast. I just, I've run out of
stories. I don't know how many more.
I like the amount of times I
tell the story and I, yeah,
I probably told this one before,
but uh, I mean, you know,
everybody's got your classic
half dozen dozen stories.
Unless you're like a guy
like Jim Jefferies and you
just live in like a classic
story.
It seems everything,
an active alcoholic. If you're an
active alcoholic and you, he's nice.
He's sober now. Yeah. Yeah. He's been,
he's been, he's been been a good boy for,
they'll come for a couple of
years. Jim, even if he isn't,
I'm not going to say
he's an active alcoholic.
I gotta just got to sit there and be like,
you know,
he likes having a good time that Jim
Jefferies, he came in one time and he was,
I think still gone from the night
before. It was quite enjoyable. I like,
I don't drink anymore, but like I love
the guy who's drunk like on the air. Oh,
it's awful to deal with in real life in
the air. It's like a phone in a firm.
It's great radio. God there he
brought in who that big Irish can be.
Andrew something. He's one of the biggest
words. He doesn't rain is an Ireland. Oh,
okay. Man on Saint Patty's day and he was
fucking loaded. Not, not Tommy turning.
No, no, no. We've had him
too. And he was the sober,
this guy I think is bigger than Tommy and
uh, he was just so drunk and obnoxious.
It was just funny to watch this guy who
in his home country, his and he's now,
he's like Kevin Hart, Right. Dot.
Just loaded and fucking seven o'clock in
the morning, blathering making no sense.
And I'm like, this is about who you
are. God, it don't drink anymore.
No, they don't. They don't fuck
around over there. Like it is a, uh,
it's a whole other,
but I mean there's definitely,
it's not like everybody
over there is a drunk,
but like there isn't like that I should,
I'm saying this is a tourist.
I just didn't see the level of concern
where everybody's so worried about
everybody over here. Like,
do you think he has a PR?
I'm really concerned about so and so.
Like I didn't feel that vibe over there.
It was more like, um, if you felt you had
a problem, maybe you tried to go to a,
an animal if they have AA over there. Is
that, is that worldwide? Has that spread?
Yeah. It's made it everywhere. Russia
has no, it doesn't, it doesn't,
does it everywhere has it?
Yeah.
That's what I've been told
about the youtube clips of
just like people saying it
in all different languages. You know?
That's a good question. I've never looked,
from what I understand,
the,
it is anonymous so people don't state
their affiliation with it publicly.
That's right. You wouldn't film it.
They probably wouldn't allow that. Yeah.
They'd try to frown on some guy with a
fucking fucking moron. How would you know?
I mean, people fill me anonymous
meeting. This is the level,
this is the level of intellect
that you're going to get on this.
So fucking settle in.
There's nothing wrong with that.
It's one of those things where
everything is online anyway.
Everything is via the fact that the
fucking first tower getting a hit,
there's a clip of that.
I don't have a windscreen on that. So
you're popping on your keys a little bit.
Uh, so that's, that's my, that's my fault.
Sorry. My last one, my five days a week,
10 years. And I don't know not
to go into a fucking microphone
with the fact that that's my ob by the
way, says bullet and not put, he'll say,
did you put that down?
Like there's certain words
he says P is B because he,
he went to broadcasting school castings
can eat. That. Sounds like such a,
such a broadcasting school.
His thing.
No, they didn't in college. You learned,
I think you learned in college actually,
but he, you know, he went
from communications. But, um,
the fact that there is footage of the
first tower getting hit like that plane
going in,
you know,
back then everyone didn't have the cell
phones at the cameras is a miracle.
Like so it's not surprising that people
think that things are going to be filmed.
I don't know why I'm on this tangent
but it's not surprising to me.
Okay.
I'm glad that was a tangent cause I was
like trying to adjust the level there as
you adjust the microphone away
from him. I was like, oh my God,
it's all about nine 11. Where the
hell did we go? Just for a second.
I just started like a weird thing
to be on film just as a color. Yeah,
just a little something.
Just a little cells to bring us
back to how lucky we are. Bill,
how Walker would it be if I just
mentioned had 11 and started blubbering.
Anything worse than somebody cries like
way too long after. And I was sitting in,
in Jim's fucking fabulous hotel
rooms so that would really be fucking
uncomfortable. Creepy on. It'd
be as long as the mikes are on.
And I feel there's an audience,
even though I can't see him. Yeah,
it wouldn't be that bad. But if,
if we would just here by ourselves,
which fucking takes me back to a
moment, Cleveland, that I, yes,
I was in a hotel room,
pissed and you fucking knocked on the
door and talk me off the fucking ledge.
It was, it was the Gig after
the Philly gig where I was like,
I knew that they were going to boot me
again, just the Boomi rather than Philly.
They booed me cause they
didn't like me. And then, um,
by the time the fucking Cleveland Gig,
you guys gave me so much props that
the crowd wanted to see it again.
So I was asking, uh, somebody there, hey,
just put me on early. Give
me a chance. Just give me a
chance. Ever. He's like, yeah,
yeah, yeah, don't worry. And then
I was in the exact same spot.
I go out there and I just walk out,
I'm on for two seconds.
They just start bullying me, just
the Boomi. And I was like, look,
I'm not going to pretend to get mad
because you guys are pretending to Boomi.
And it didn't go anywhere.
I got off stage and I was fucking livid.
I remember me and Jeff will still
laugh about it because Jeff was like,
oh, I'm sorry. I was like, fuck
you. Fuck you, fuck this state,
fuck everything. And I left. I think I
threw a water bottle. Very unhappy. I was,
I was not happy and are not cause me,
I catastrophize in my head.
So I was like going, oh my God, I
become the boom guy and I'm going to go.
And everywhere I go,
I kind of forgot because I had been on
the virus tour long enough that to me a
normal show was fucking 10,000 people.
And I wasn't thinking like my next gig
after that tour was at the punchline.
It's like a cozy 200 people and
I can see everyone, you know?
And so if anybody fucked with me,
I could get them. And so anyways,
so I go back to the fucking hotel
room, uh, ready to quit the business.
And I hear a knock on the door and you
came walking in and fucking talk me off
the ledge.
I remember that. I don't even
remember what we spoke about it.
I just remember you were very upset
and I knew why and you will like they
fucking, and I was like, dude,
they did it because they were trying to
recapture a moment that they want it to
be a part of something that was very
amazing to them as opposed to they hated
you. You know what I mean? I didn't, I was
fenced. Everyone was out to get
me the, the crowd, the show,
uh, uh, not live nation. Everybody.
Well, I'm still convinced
about that. Fuck me.
I couldn't get the odd ball tour this
year. I can't get on the eyeball touring.
They're doing fucking the tweeter
center and, and late half those please.
What's that? You've played half of
those places and I can't get on the,
I couldn't get a fucking
set on the odd ball. Ah,
or they'll have it next year. Yeah. I
know. This shit is guys like you and me.
We always got to fucking, we always got
to go the extra fucking whatever it is.
It was always remember that when they
were doing the half hours on, on a,
on comedy central or,
or the whatever the fuck that was,
it was always the guy with the silly hat.
The person with the catch phrase,
the hot chick, the fat guy, you know,
the blackout doesn't scare white people.
They had to get through all of those and
then they also had to get the veterans
that they fucked over on the
last group of half hours.
They have to give her to all of
those fucking guys. And then,
and then it was always us afterwards.
I ever did with for comedy central.
I was so resentful over being passed over.
I was like, Frito, I just was like,
fuck these guys. I'm not going to do it.
And then I waited for him.
Not like everybody says,
well that's the way Doug wanted it.
Yeah.
I wound up,
uh,
said I want to hold that for HBO and a
that when we finally did them for Hbo and
they were supposed to do four and they
were going to be really these special
half hours and now they want to do
in 10 of them and I'm, you know,
I'm happy we did it.
I'm glad I held off for Hbo.
Yeah, you did. And you did the same
year, the same year that I did it.
Well you all we want to, okay. I take with
Patrice. You taped with Kevin Brennan,
right? I still remember that. And
then the Louis C K Yep. One time.
Um, you know, cause I'm obsessed with
trying to own everything I did, you know,
I tried to buy my half hour back from Hbo,
but they wanted me to buy the whole,
I had to buy the whole fucking series.
I did buy like all 10 of them know how
much they want out Jesus. It was like,
you know, in the millions. So it was
just, I mean, I was looking at it like,
well it costs me 130 to shoot it our,
so I ought to be able to offer them.
She fucking 65 and they were like, no,
you have to buy the whole season
and like, you know, fuck it.
I don't know some of the thing to throw
money at the sopranos or something to
get it,
but I wish I had the money because,
but nowadays everyone just steals
everything anyone says probably dumb.
But when I was looking back at that,
I'm like, that series is fucking insane.
That's you, Patrice O'Neal rest his
soul is the fucking greatest I ever saw.
Louie earthquake flight of the Conchords
was wider. The Conchords was one.
That's right.
I forgot they were on it.
They wanted me to do it with
those guys and I did to,
I did one and I was just like,
uh, you know, I think once,
what's his face bot delirious
off of them. They were shy. They,
we've got a little gun shy. Oh, he owns
it now Murphy. I didn't know that. No.
What's his face coming up next?
Comics unleashed that guy. Oh, Byron.
Byron Allen bought that Motherfucker,
delirious.
Hbo showed that fucking thing. And
then they just, when we were kids,
teenagers and uh,
they just never showed it again.
They had it in their library and somehow
Byron Allen went in there and bought it
off of him. How much? Right. But
I don't know what he paid for it.
Like a couple million bucks.
And right before the whole DVD thing died,
he put it out,
it like 15,
20 a whack and he sold like 4
million of them are some genius.
That guy. He is. And a lot
of people don't really,
I don't like talking about people's money,
but this fucking guy,
it's like this guy,
he has like three quarters Oprah
money and people don't even know.
They just look at him like he's
one of those guys, like, you know,
like how Seinfeld sees his show, where
everybody else sees just hanging out.
He's one of those guys like
I saw at Seinfeld on uh, um,
the daily show the other day talking to
Jon Stewart and they were joking how he
was saying how he did TV, right?
How he just did it, did it once.
It lives forever. And Jon Stewart, when he
does an episode of the daily show, it's,
it's all topicals.
So no one's going to buy the box set of
the fucking day on Shell. And um, Jesus,
I'm taking the long way around here.
So he was talking about the new TV show
he's doing, uh, on the, on on the net,
which is fucking comedians in
cars getting coffee. And he said,
which is what I would doing anyway,
right? So Byron Allen was a guy,
took those press junkets when
you were just like, well, it was,
it like to work with Steven
Spielberg, talk about Mel
Gibson, blah, blah, blah, blah.
All that he actually saw show and then
that's where he came up with that coming
up. Next thing it was just
a fucking press junkets.
And what's coming up next is
that he would say common up next.
Jim Norton and talking about the vice
show that he's on and blah, blah blah.
And he turned that,
he turned that into a fucking TV show.
That comics unleashed is genius.
It's literally just, and, and
it's the worst setups of all time.
Is it just do your act for
three minutes at a clip,
but it's fucking jeans and
he produces the whole thing.
He owns the whole fucking guy.
A gene.
Like he's like a hero of mine is far as
like the way he does like this business.
And he's basically for people, a of
this is to uh, go into quick here.
He basically that show,
if you don't watch it,
it's just Byron Allen sitting there
with three or four other comics.
He already knows what your bits are.
So you've already written the
whole fucking show for him.
And all he does is just say your
set up like, so Jim, uh, you ever a,
you ever lived in a fucking building
in New York and then you're likable,
murder for,
go ahead.
And the other comment on that drug,
cause nobody's calling each other out.
Like they're all like just
participating in like,
it is a really a good time we're having
like how can three comedians sit there
and listen to a guy do a bit off that
setup and not want to fuck and attack them
or they can't do that. Cause then
they'd get sued by tough crowd. Yeah.
You don't want, I guess that's what that,
that's what made tough crowd funding
crown was fucking awesome that we,
that has such a, such a cult following.
Do you know, people stay asked
me like just as much for a first,
just along a time,
like when Chappelle show coming back,
when's tough crowd coming back?
Those two shows had like, uh,
these die hard fans and
I, I still don't, um,
I don't understand what
about calling I'd get,
he got his own show and he gave every
comedian in New York a TV credit just
about, like I, I was trying to, I remember
towards the, the last, a season of that,
I was trying to think of somebody who
hadn't been on it. He got everybody on.
I think he did. Yeah, it was Bobby.
Bobby was an irregular on it,
but Bobby was on it a couple
of times. Um, I, yeah. Oh,
I thought he was under quite a
bit. No, I don't think he was.
I could be wrong about that. Maybe
I'm thinking open ethic. He's,
he didn't do opie and Anthony on new, he
didn't do that too. We're on satellite,
so maybe he was on tough
crowd more than I thought.
But I remember him being talked about
warm up for it at one point and like,
I don't want to fuck that
one up there. You know, man,
Bobby. So I think that, uh, he,
it's a very short fuse, so I think that
he was on a few times, but I didn't,
I don't think I ever did it with
them. Right. They get mad at me too.
He got mad at me cause I remember
that we went to Vegas, like I met,
we went to Vegas together, but not the
actual fight and he got very angry at me.
I'm like, yeah. I'm like, yeah, that
was your IFA. But it's like, fuck dude,
I know I was fucking now with Ya.
I'm like, oh, all right, sorry.
I can't make fun of liberty
for having a temper.
But he's another guy who,
he's always had to go the extra fucking
12 miles. He's just one of those guys.
He does got that short thing.
I remember one time I was walking down
the street with them when he was talking,
you know, when we all just start
complaining about the business.
So he was complaining about the
business and he was going to, uh,
he was going to help me with the complete,
you know, he's great with the computer.
So he was going to help me.
And as we were walking,
I used to live around the corner
from him and I'm thinking, well,
my computer is up on the, you know, the
fucking whatever, the seventh floor,
and he's on the ground floor
and I'm thinking in my head,
let me go out and get the computer
and we'll take it over to his house.
So as he's telling like his, you know,
fucking 20 the story about this business,
I said, hey Bob, what if I can I just go
up and get that age just fucking snapped.
And he goes,
HM,
don't
fuck
did on ninth avenue and like
broad daylight and you do
it like everybody fucking,
you know, people look in and shit.
And I just looked at him like,
and the old me would have taken the bait
and I would've gotten to this big fuck
you fuck you fight. And I don't
even know if this is the new me.
I just was not an,
I don't know,
I just wasn't in a place
where I was mad or anything.
He so came on a nowhere that I just
kind of looked at. I was like, Bob,
I thought we kind of got past doing
this to each other and then he kind of
laughed and it was gone,
which he's always been able to do as
much as that guy flips the fuck out,
he's able to bring it back down and be
like, I do at least and do it. I'm like,
he's not a grudge holder. I started, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So he fucking, uh,
that was like an instant Bobby
classic. Don't interrupt me. Yeah,
that's what a great line echoing.
I just like how he said it.
Like I worked for him.
Like I felt like he should have been
behind some big walnut desk. Oh, is it?
Maybe we could do this.
Don't interrupt
made contact.
I'm talking cause you fucked this up.
You don't just be so happy.
That makes me so that,
that's a fucking Bobby scream and I'm
really happy that that happened to
somebody other than me. Oh No. He's a
frightening guy. When he fucking yells.
I hate to admit it, but Bobby's a
fucking maniac. He does scare me.
I would call them a maniac,
but that's a, that's the one
plot and kettle there. I'm out of my
fucking mind dude. Like when I'm out here,
I literally had to make a rule
about just relaxing when I drive.
And w one thing that it helps is very
therapeutic for me is letting people go.
If you're really like,
I get so frustrated with the
quality of the driving out here,
the inability to fucking make
turns at a decent speed and,
and we'll do it when they go buy shit out
here. The second they pass it, it's it.
They don't even remember it. They
have no fears, no fucking clue.
As for what's behind you.
Like you know what they do here,
I'd hear that fucking drives me nut.
You'll be sitting behind some
guy to a red light, you know,
in Europe on his bumper.
You know,
like you're supposed to be not in
crazy and it's the light turns green.
He then puts his left fucking director.
It's absolute enraging and it's self
centered and yet it's, it's, it's,
I'm with you.
It's wrong that I fantasize about pushing
him into traffic and know it's wrong.
You don't have the moral courage to do it.
That's totally,
I think that's totally right.
And whenever you hear about someone
getting shot and killed for road rage,
everyone folks goes, oh my
God, that maniac that shot
that. And I honest to God,
the first thing I think is I'm glad like
and until I find out that guy with the
gun was the Dick who who fucked up.
I love that you have to find out
that the guy with the gun was a dick.
I know to find that out.
The guy with the gun overreacted a little,
but it's just there's something about,
because people are so self centered
and narcissistic when they drive it,
it's a reflection of who they really are,
so that's why we take it so fucking
personally may like you let people go.
If the guy, if a guy doesn't wave
thank you to me, that's awesome.
No sin,
they don't do that out here and I go from
like being this fucking mother Theresa
Person. I turned it to
the devil. It starts,
I try to stay calm as such with a couple
of release in my car. I just got really,
really, really, you're not going to
fuck these fucking people out of here.
I don't know what the fuck are you.
I ended up turning into that
just because some douche.
Do you see the look on their face? They're
like, please, please, please let me go.
And you go to let them go
and you think like, Oh hey,
thumbs up something. Nothing.
They immediately, I just
back into their own. Uh,
I dunno.
I find sometimes I wave at people out
here and they look at me like weird.
Like what do you know me?
Like maybe you know,
I did move 2,500 miles away
from where I learned, you know,
societal rules. So maybe uh, but you
know, you just think if you know,
you're waving to another white guy. I
mean we're pretty fucking generic. Yeah.
You know,
there's not a lot of depth to the culture.
Sure. Here is that there's no gang
signs right away. I can see black guys,
he'll freak out watching which
point your fingers are turning.
Well plus he's Costo is so aggressive
and I hate to do like get all your thing.
But out here maybe that courtesy,
like you know in Boston or New York,
if someone lets you cut it and it's like,
Hey motherfucker,
I did you occur to seeing like,
Hey,
thank you for the car to say you're a
good shit though. Welcome, you're welcome.
But here it's like,
well that was just expected because they
might do that for each other more out
here. It's not a big deal.
That's the only I can think of.
I was in the Pennsylvania turnpike one
time driving to a Gig and I know I'm
popping all over every,
I'm very self conscious talking
is how are you doing? What? You're
doing much better. But I don't have,
I don't have anybody to
help us out with this.
Okay.
I was driving to a Gig and a guy cut
into my lane and I was doing about 70 it
was raining and he had a trailer,
normal.
And I'm like hydro,
you know, it was a real drive
to with my Mustang, real punk,
your shit fucking
hydroplane and cargo recall.
And I'm driving and this guy is
coming into my lane and I immediately,
your mind when you're thinking you're
going to die, it goes very quickly.
And I'm like, okay, you
got to slam on the brakes,
you're going to have an accident,
hit the wall. Like it tried to,
it's self down, sideswiped the
wall. So I jam on the brake,
I hit the horn and he veers out
and we don't have the accident.
So then I'm not afraid I'm in a
rage at this fucking guy. Right.
And I pull up next to him and it's a,
it's a like a,
you don't have a fat
black dude like it all.
Family Mopey guy and I'm ready to really,
you know we've went from family guy
actually. Yes. William Stephenson fellows
and now he looks at me and he gives me the
like, oops, I fucked up ways up. Sorry.
And it gives me that and
every bit of drink cause
he, he just owned up to it. I'm sorry.
Sorry. Yet I wave back. No problem. Yeah,
that was it in a second my rage,
it was gone. You know what's funny,
I sometimes when somebody acts on the
rage, even though I know it's wrong,
I sort of lived through the,
the fucking ecstasy
that that must be like,
do you remember when Russell Crowe
through the phone? I said, Guy,
I just can't imagine,
like when you're in a hotel and you're
not getting the customer service you want
on whatever it is,
that the fact that you actually take the
machine that they won't help you with
and fucking hurt somebody,
the person who not helping you,
you fucking hurt him with it. Completely
wrong thing to do. But I can't imagine.
I always was wondering why is he's
letting that phone go? Just Ah,
just fucking all that rage going on him.
I think it was, it was good for him.
It was bad for the guy behind the,
uh,
by the counter behind the
counter was brought to people,
learned a lesson that day.
Russell Crowe learn not to do it.
The other guy probably learned better
fucking customer service next time because
I remember when that happened,
I was in the Greenwich Hotel and uh,
it was Dinero owns and I remember like,
Oh my God, that's a really nice place.
It's beautiful. Like he would stay
at a die from a stupid comment,
but I remember thinking this satisfaction,
it must've felt when
the phone hit the guy,
like how good that must've felt a throw
that phone with that motherfucker.
And again, he got in big trouble for that.
But yeah, that was a story that I do.
You know how mad you are you,
you're pulling the wires out of the wall
and that voice is still not going, okay,
what are you doing? What are you
doing? And then you wrap it up,
you leave your hotel, you're walking
down the hall, he leave Your Room,
you get into the fucking elevator
and your brain's still going. Yeah,
throw it at him. Yeah, throw it
out. What happened? Well, I mean he,
he went downstairs to the front.
I mean I don't,
I was just wanting to pick the phone up
off the desk and just do it on them. Oh,
I thought he was upstairs in his room.
Maybe he was, but I thought the, I didn't,
I didn't, I thought he just picked
the phone up and threw it. The guy.
That makes way more sense if I find out
that he actually wrapped the cord and
took the phone from downstairs.
That makes me love him more. I was,
I loved him just for picking it up.
I probably fucked it up.
I fucked up everything.
I don't know.
Do you know the other day I
actually called the periodic chart.
I called it the periodical.
Yeah,
but that's understanding on the ones
that was a magazine ad. That's no excuse.
That's like you're on a fear on a
western. You call it a cow boy. Yet.
How do you not fucking know?
It shows you the amount
of fucking research I did
through sometimes on Twitter.
Where do you get trashed?
It's just so fucking on the money.
And I always read it as if people
would just be in mean to be mean.
But when they call me out for the,
all the stupid shit, it really, uh,
it makes being on Twitter worth it.
Cause other than hyper and your shows,
it's usually just a bunch of people giving
you shit artist with half the fucking
information pause on that.
Um, they fucking, and then,
then it just becomes like a,
you know, it just becomes like,
why am I on this thing? Because it
will literally put you in a bad mood.
And then every once in a while somebody
like that guy waving, you know,
in the car,
he just gives you shit in the right
way and it makes you fucking laugh.
You retweet, they select your,
retweet them and it just,
it becomes like, all right,
I'm fucking cool with Twitter again.
I have a piece of, of criticism,
somebody's bashed me all the time,
but actually have it on my desktop and I,
I've opened it a few times and read it.
It was just about like, you know, I
used to love Jim, but he knew the,
but the guy made some valid points as
to what I do wrong on the radio and a
about how like, and I felt this
constructive criticism, but he was mad,
but I actually felt like,
Eh,
this is actually coming from the guy who
was a fan and who just thinks I've been
quite a con for a while and uh,
you know what,
I read it and it just resonated with
me. Like this guy is not wrong. I mean,
I don't like what he said, very mature
way of handling criticism. But yeah,
I normally it's, it's, it's
much more like rage full.
I want to find out who they are and I,
you know, I get very, very angry and uh,
this time it just, it just
got me right. I'm like,
I know he's being honest and he's
like, oh, I have been doing that.
It feels exposing when some stranger just
notices you're fucking your weaknesses
and your crutches.
I've had a couple of heckles like the,
Oh they kind of put you in your place and
you gotta be like, you want to be like,
Ooh, do you do for a living? That's
soaks. But you have to be like,
I finally learned at one point,
oh you know something I actually
learned about handle a heckler is in a
different way. Watching you.
I did down at Caroline's,
it finally clicked.
I learned through watching you,
you don't have to chop all their heads
off. Sometimes they are ordering food.
Sometimes they're just repeating
a, a punchline. Like I saw,
I forget what you, you,
they were talking and you just kind of
said something. What'd you say? Oh okay.
And, and you kind of like, you
actually ask them what they said.
I think that that's what it was rather
than just assuming that they were
trashing you saying that you sucked it
cause he amount of times I kept having
this reoccurring thing where someone,
if anybody talked,
I was convinced they were saying that I
sucked and they would make fun of how I
looked at whatever and
I was the first eight,
nine years of my career and I would chop
the heads off and the amount of times
afterwards people would come up to
me at the end to show shows going.
I was just asking where the bathroom was
or I was actually saying I enjoyed your
act and blah blah blah blah blah. And
then I felt like I couldn't get out of it.
Man. I like, I was locked in this, you
know, get 'em, get 'em, get 'em, get 'em,
get 'em kind of vibe. And then I
was watching you and I and I was,
it took me a while to learn how to do
well I had one too.
It's once in a while that'll happen at
the cellar because that's such a loud,
small area where you'll
say something to say,
you'll hear somebody talking and I can
always see if it's somebody ordering a
drink that I leave it alone. Um,
you know, cause it's a small room.
But once in a while you'll hear talking
and I've had a few people like over the
years go, like, what? What will you
say? I just think, I think you're funny.
I'm enjoying you.
And then I've just kind of now,
then I repeat that and I just kind of
get the audience to laugh at me with it
because it's like, all right,
they all know I was about
to attack the person. Yeah.
They all know that this
was an almost heckle.
And so did you always do
that or is that something,
I think I learned it in a place called,
uh, Arba John's, which was a two.
I first met Arie Spears back
in the 1991 when he was going,
his mom would bring him to open mikes and
he would do these robo cop impressions,
but he was too young to
get him by himself. So his
mother took him and it was a,
a Sheraton bar area and I had just
had felt a wave of depression.
I probably did that Gig. Yeah. Oh
yeah. Well, East Brunswick, New Jersey.
What did you start? What
year? I started marching 92.
Okay. Yeah. So you might have,
it was right around that time.
Well, I started up a Massachusetts and
then I worked, I got down to New York. Uh,
I probably did my first road
gig out there and in 95 oh six,
but I remember going out to those,
some of those Jersey ones in those hotels.
Awful.
Yeah.
They will either great or you just would
driving home fucking that thousand yard
stare. Like, oh my God, what have I done?
I remember doing one with
Vinny, Brandon, Bob Levy,
where there was a pool I believe
in between us and the audience.
I'll never forget that gay.
We were on one side,
there's a holiday inn and it was in the
pool area and we were an obvious place
for a competent,
wonderful place to try your art.
Wet feet slapping by as you're fucking
China do your jokes. That was really bad.
I remember Vinny or we were in the front,
but I remember there was a pool,
I think between us in the crowd, but
in their orbit. Jordan's, we've always,
I was smashing a heckler arbit John and
nobody was laughing in the back and then
I realized like, oh, they
can't hear what is being said.
Repeat what they say a it buys you a
couple of seconds and nobody knows you're
doing it right. We were like, how with the
audience we know, we're like, you know,
someone's like, you know you suck.
You're terrible. I suck and I'm terrible.
It's like you've just bought yourself
and if you hit them, tried it.
Priceless time. Yeah.
Yeah. It's really weird.
I don't know how to explain this to
people. When, when, when people like,
how'd you come up with that that fast?
Like I don't know.
When you see a funny moment,
I don't mean a written joke,
but if someone slams you and you're
great at fucking firing back immediately
like Donald Hammond said he sees
impressions as colors like a yellow or an
orange.
He can't explain it.
When I see like slamming
something as like,
it's like these weird
choices you're making,
they're kind of floating in front of you.
Like you don't see the words
but is that why you self,
cause you got the fastest mind if anybody,
and we used to sit at the table at the
seller do when you is Patrice was like
she would just make you fucking, yeah,
you'd start crying when he was the best.
But like as far as speed,
like I thought Patrice,
a lot of times he would use
his laugh to drown you out.
Like he had all these different things.
You would just sit there.
I remember when you'd start looking at me
I was like, oh fuck he's looking at me.
He's looking. It was a different thing.
Like with Keith, I felt Keith Robinson,
Keith,
you could get,
you could get a mitness face to
try to throw him off like Keith,
stop looking at me,
blah blah blah.
And that would make them forget what he
was going to say. But you never forgot.
And Voss,
all you had to do with via techniques
for all of you guys survive the Voss.
All you had to do was lay on the ropes
and eventually he would say something
that bombed and then it would come
back on him. He always got bit,
he would hit you one,
two,
three times and then that fourth or
fifth one would be so bad at bombed that
everyone would then jump on him.
So you never really had to get them back
voice what voice would be
pounding you and pounding you.
But he always got greedy and
throw a right hand lead. Yeah,
you always punch himself out.
Always Punch himself out.
But how do you see when you, when you're,
whether it's a heckler, whatever, how do,
I can't explain to people
how that works. Like, how,
how do you think of a joke
or a funny thing to say it?
It's almost like watching things float
in front of you and you grab them.
I look at it more like in
the beginning it was like,
remember like I have to have
these stock lines, right? Hey,
where'd you learn how to whisper
helicopter, helicopter factory?
Like what is that they're already on.
It didn't even make sense
and it always got a laugh.
Um,
but it was more like those,
I had those stock lines
and then it became,
I would watch and Greg Fitzsimmons and
I've told him this before in his show,
I learned from Greg where
Greg would just ask him, like,
Greg is fucking unbelievable on.
He's so good at it.
Fucking with people in the crowd and what
time we would play in this place. The,
the grill 93. And uh, oh my God,
where was it was up. It was on route 93
messages. Yeah, it was not Arlington.
That was the way Dane was falling.
Springfield,
I can't even over to get with an a, I
don't remember. And um, Andover mass.
And over, there you go. Yeah,
the grill 93 in Andover mass.
And these two guys showed up with matching
American flag shirts and they sat in
the front row and Greg was so good at
trash and people like I was either hosting
or featuring, but me and the host or me
and the feature both said to Greg, Greg,
we're not going to fuck with those guys,
but you have to promise us that you're
going to write at the beginning.
Go after him. And he goes, absolutely.
Absolutely. So we deliberately did not,
none of these guys
wanted to get picked on.
And Greg ended up going up there and
he just started telling this story.
They've just went all the way around
the fucking band at this point.
People are like, what is he talking
about? Some high buy around the beach,
you know what I mean? That
would be like, I dunno,
like wearing matching American flags
shirts with your friends or something.
And then he just pointed at the guys and
opened his mouth like David Lee Roth,
you know, when he looks at the back row
and it just fucking absolutely destroyed.
I saw my time at the cow, Luna,
he eat fucking heat by that.
It was like Hannibal Lecter should,
he could tell by the
shoes the guy was wearing,
he guessed the guy's name and for
guests is, he guessed his job,
the table the guy was sitting at
was going nuts and it was just all,
and of course his name was horrible.
His job was horrible.
Where he lived was horrible. He started,
he did a little vignette of their family.
Like he's unbelievable at
doing stuff like that. So,
so that's funny when people ask me,
you know who your influences as well,
that was, you know, as much as it was
the, the grates that you listened to.
People don't understand that.
Not only did you learn, you know,
I was a tell CK and all
those guys too are beyond me.
But I learned watching guys that were, uh,
you know, breaking in at the same time.
Yeah, we starting to, cause I, I
a lot of times you were, you were,
you would get yourself into the same
situation that a more seasoned guide
wouldn't. And I would watch
you get out of it and be like,
oh I never thought to do it that way.
Right.
That's how you scale.
That's how you take it and stop it before
it goes off the cliff. And the whole,
cause I I realized too that a lot of
times I would lose crowds by hitting too
hard. Like you know a guy throws
up something that deserves a four.
It's almost like in the right to, I hope
you get aids. Yeah. Right. Two of them.
Yeah. Like what's that? What's
that? Fucking wife's got cancer.
What does totally unnecessary it
was in the crowd hates you for it.
So it's like the worst is when
someone's heckling you in the front.
I'll never forget this guy heckling
me are rascals. I was a new comic.
But even back then I knew this guy
was being a twat cause he was, he ski,
he was heckling me and it wasn't
horrible shifted, he was saying.
But it was his eyes.
Like I knew he's the fucking,
that scumbag in the office who's resentful
that he's not up here getting laughs,
you're gay. Yeah. And the
audience can't see it.
So I was pounded them and I
really ruined his night. And uh,
the crowd hated before,
but as I couldn't see what a dick he was,
you know how like, you know, you
just know. Yeah, of course I do.
And you could always tell times, I'll
never, never regret doing it though.
It's like that's 25 years ago.
It's my first year of comedy and I still
feel good that I wrecked that piece of
shits tonight cause I didn't know he
was coming out. You know what I saw?
I remember I was at the
punchline in Atlanta and I
had a guy like that and all I
can remember about what he looked like
was he had loafers with no socks and he
had fat feet. So things like the
like bolting out the front end,
he kept putting his feet on the stage. So
I made the joke to take them, you know,
to take them off or whatever.
And it's,
you know, cause he really, you know, had,
and he's just was fucking annoying me
and it was just the fact that he kept
putting him back. I knew that
it wasn't, oh, I'm sorry,
I just need to stretch my legs out.
There was some sort of power things
go when you breathe it into the mic.
Then it was like a power thing.
There was like this power thing going on
with them and it literally escalated to
the point that they had to kick
them out and eat. When he stood up,
he made sure he got on the stage and
took like half a step towards me.
And he was just, you know, this
little fucking, I don't know,
he probably was doing well in business
and he was used to people telling,
you know, telling other people
what to do and uh, but whatever.
Here we are and now we're sitting
here talking about the process.
I want to make sure that I get to the
whole reason why is a fancy man like
yourself out here in a, in Los
Angeles. You got it. You are, you,
you're working on something.
What's going on?
Well my thanks bill.
That was my advice show is uh,
coming on and uh, you know, I
just had to come out and plug it.
It's hard to plug show it,
isn't it? That's great too.
What, tell me about the show.
Happy about it to do it.
I talked to, you know,
I do a monologue.
I mean I feel ashamed of,
I explain things but I don't
know if that would ever,
it makes me a common cause that's
that fucked right. Right. Shame thing.
Collin Collin describing
his shame spiraling.
It's hosting a talk show and it's,
I always wanted to do it.
So I a I did four episodes
and you do a monologue sketch,
you're hosting a talk show. Yeah. Yeah.
That's fucking great. Yeah, I'm happy man.
It's uh, my first guests are our,
we're Tyson and Dana white together.
Then it was awesome and it was like a
really good interview and I was like,
wow man, that went well. I've never
seen, I mean this isn't a good way.
I'd never seen him give a guy like you
don't talk show. They don't. That's great.
Yeah. Cause usually it's usually telling,
you know, if you're doing a talk show,
Hey CIM pen a, tone it down a little.
So what, what uh, what channel is it on?
It's on vice.com. You know,
it's a, it's online, which
is kind of where I wanted it.
I now can you curse and stuff? Do I
you want total content freedom? Oh,
I had total content freedom.
Um, Bailey, Jay's my cohost. Um,
and she's kind of like my announcement,
you know, Bailey, lovely girl. And uh,
you know, so I think it's, I think it
turned out was Bobby's suggestions.
It's like, dude, you got to get
Bailey involved. And I think it's,
I think it's Bailey. J the,
yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
The fuck was I thinking of, I interviewed
a, you know, I interviewed freeway Rick,
you know who that the drug dealer,
the extra dealer not direct from.
Oh, that's us. That sounds
like a seventies black guy
nickname. It is. It is.
He did 20 years. Yeah, he did. And
he was a big dealer in the 80s.
He was like with the Iran Contra
scandal like he was buying,
the guy he was getting his drugs from was,
it was funneling money to
the contras and then uh,
you know Rick went to jail for,
he got life without parole but he's out
now on a technicality cause they was
like a three strikes thing,
whatever.
But they charged them twice option the
rights for this fucking great movie.
I got to own them. No one, he, Michael
K. Williams is playing him in something.
There's a reporter who broke his story
is being played by Jeremy Renner and I
think the reporter committed
suicide cause people laughed at him.
The whole Iran Contra thing and the drug
connection in the CIA putting money in
the black neighborhoods. We
had tea, I wait a minute,
they laughed at him so he
could reporters back then.
They didn't think he was right.
Like I think we were just
talking about the government,
the CIA allowing drugs
into these ghetto now bad.
Did they laugh at and he must've been
getting, fuck yeah, I expected a Pulitzer.
And they were like hanging him from
his press undies every day from the
typewriter.
Keep picking on me.
God, there's a connection there letting
the drugs could, man, I fucking feel it.
Yeah. And then he wound up, uh, blown
his brains up or be improving. Right.
We've let t I was t I was on a week
before I interviewed Rick Ross and we were
like, Eh, it sounded kind of power.
Like those are great guests. Tea,
I always opening out to the,
not on a whatever, but he
was talking about the, the,
the drugs wouldn't have like,
everyone's like, ah, I don't know.
It sounded a little bit conspiracy and
then requested the same thing. I'm like,
fuck man. See, I was right.
Like I've heard it from too many
different sources that the CIA apologized.
It was really interesting.
So he was a good interview.
And then I did a couple of,
uh, comedians and uh, you know,
hopefully it will do more. Nah, dude,
you gotta when's this coming out?
This Wednesday, July 23rd. And
I can't say what time, like I
guess when, when are they going to,
I don't know. I'll just Twitter it.
I'm not sure. They, they, you know,
it's like they,
I don't know how this one works.
Like I'm used to doing
promotion for stuff. Like I
know exactly what day it's on,
I know exactly what time it on.
The first episode is being released
in two parts because it's a, you know,
so it's like a 45 minute interview
plus 20 other minutes of content.
So it's like one day and then the next
day and they can watch the whole thing.
Yeah.
Does that sounds like a great, great
guest. And then, you know, sidekick,
nobody has anybody like Bailey J.
That's great.
And then usually a guy like you
doesn't get you guys, they usually,
you're usually the guy, the way
they're like, all right. You know,
just tone it down, tone it down.
So the see a, a real, I can't say,
I don't want to insult anybody,
but like somebody might
taste like actually going out
doing a monologue and that
type of stuff that you're going to
pick on. That's fucking awesome, man.
It felt so nice to not have to tone it
down because in one of the episodes I
just did a bunch of sterling stuff
which I've been doing on stage.
It's like how long is that going
to be good for you? And um,
I like, it was a fun one. Oh God. I
hope he lives forever. I hope with the,
my angle on it's still cause
my specialist coming out and I,
and I was able to turn that into some,
like I'm hoping I,
the point that I'm making,
uh, is still relevant.
Is there anything worse than when
you shoot something and it winds up,
something happens in the meantime,
which dates the reference or the bats?
Yeah. No, but it happens because this is,
I think sometimes I try not to overthink
that thing where, you know, if you,
even a guy like Richard Pryor,
I talked about the heavyweights
of his time cause you know,
there's some comics are like,
you know,
don't do anything w where anything
that's going to make you look fucking,
you know, in three years I'll be like the
cutting edge fashion. Like take you a,
like Sinbad, like some of the stuff that
that guy wore, you know what I mean?
Like some of that sh just in general,
some of the shit from the early nineties,
late eighties, early nineties was pretty
out there. Um, so some people try to go,
just wear black on black,
very kind of simple thing.
And then don't do anything topical
because it's going to date you're special.
And it's like, who gives a fuck? Who
Cares? Yeah. I don't if it's a great joke,
it's a great joke. Like,
uh, that prior one,
I forget he's talking
about the old retired black
fighter who was refereeing in
the ref,
one of the fighters with beating the
shit out of a white guy and he didn't,
he was joking that the guy wouldn't stop
it. Oh Shit. He looks okay. Whatever.
And that's still funny. Yeah,
it's still fucking funny.
So I think if the joke is there, it,
let's see. I'm trying to convince me.
What did fryers say? And it's, it's, it
was a Jerry quarry joke, right about,
it was something that, how he just, he
just loves black people beating them up.
And it made me laugh so hard.
And it was 40 years after he said it.
It doesn't matter.
Woody Allen stuff,
he does references from the early sixties
it's hilarious. Yeah. Climate opens,
one of the specialists, you know
the Reagan people, I don't care.
I learned who Jerry quarry
was through Richard Pryor.
I didn't know who James Brown was
until Eddie Murphy did the bit.
I was that white, like the
world I was living in and, and,
and people will be like, how
the fuck did that? How did,
how did you not know who he
was? And it was like, well,
my parents were that fucking white. And
then there was three channels, you know?
Right. And there was no internet
and it was like, you know,
I,
I knew who the fucking Jefferson's war.
I mean that was like the only thing that
was on TV, it seemed, but good times.
But as far as stuff like that was
really difficult for a guy like him.
Even when he became an icon. You
know, I just saw it recently.
He did like the Mike Douglas show.
We did some shows, but I mean,
I was a little kid so I just didn't seem
so, I remember laughing at the eddy.
I told Charlie this story and he was
beside himself. He was almost offended.
He goes, get the fuck outta here.
Fuck debt. You knew who he was.
Your parents knew who he was like,
I didn't,
I didn't know who arguably the greatest
performer of the last century was.
Um, GRC. James Brown and
Pavarotti. They get us. They did.
It's a man's world together. How awesome.
It was. Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
They really liked each other, but that was
a really, I love stuff like that. Yeah.
When they like,
to me that that's a mashup.
Like I don't like when they just take
two songs that have the same tempo when
it's supposed to blow my
fucking mind. It's like, yeah,
well if you get two
songs at the same speed,
get dropped some shit out and
you throw some shit in. Right.
Not that I could ever
figure out how to do it. No,
I couldn't say there's a genius to it,
but I still resent it the same.
I understand the hating it like I respect.
It's hard to do but fuck them.
It's that stinks.
All right everybody,
here's the advertising for this week.
I apologize for the bad edit.
I just interviewed Jim on like Friday
or something when he was in town and you
know we just did that straight through
without the advertising because I didn't
have it yet.
So now I am in my house,
it's like seven 30 Monday morning and
my wife is still sleeping so I gotta
I gotta read in this creepy voice so
you're gonna have to fucking deal with it.
All right?
You just fucking deal with it.
This is going to be my
voice dollar shave club.
Everybody at the big razor
companies think we're stupid.
Every year they roll out some ridiculous
shaving technology gimmick and expect
us to flip out and shell
out big bucks for it.
Do you really need a razor with a
vibrating handle or a roller pivot ball,
back scratch or egg timer, laser pointer
corkscrew. You get the point, okay.
You don't need it.
All right.
We were all just shave and fine before
any of that crap and I personally
definitely don't need to spend
my hat earned cash on it. Um,
if you're sick of being
treated like a moron,
join the hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of smarter people who joined the
dollar.
Shave club.com revolution.
Dollar Shave Club delivers the best
blades in grooming supplies for just a few
bucks a month.
That blades are better than the big shape
companies for a fraction of the price
in.
My listeners can get started
now@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burr and hey,
if you're already a member member,
you got to go check out Dr
Covey's post shave lotion.
It's the perfect way to make peace with
your face after the disruptive act of
shaving. Stop getting ripped
off by the big shave companies.
Join Dollar Shave club.com/burr that's
dollar shave club.com/bar all right,
the next one, stamps.com
quick, convenient, and most
importantly easy to use.
That's how I would describe stamps.com
it will make your mailing and shipping an
absolute breeze with stamps.com you can
buy and print official us postage using
your computer and your printer.
There's nothing to learn.
That's why I like it because I'm an idiot.
stamps.com will give you a digital
scale that autumn that automatically
calculates exact postage for any letter,
any package.
They'll even help you choose the best
class of mail to get your mail there on
time for the least amount of money.
Then drop your mail into any mailbox
or hand to your mailman and that's it.
You're done. You'll never have to go
to the post office again. Trust me,
mailing and shipping
has never been easier.
I use stamps.com to send out all
my posters, my tee shirts, DVDs,
whatever the hell I'm selling at the end
of the week and if I can figure it out.
So can you right now use my last
name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
right now. Before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
bar. All right, last one, last
one. Here we go. Legal, zoom,
everyone. Most Americans don't
have a will, but why is that?
You don't want the court dictating what
happens to your property and your minor
children. Do you? Of course you don't. So
why procrastinate? Most people say, well,
it's too expensive or it's too
time consuming, but the level blah.
I got an answer for you.
Legal zoom.com too expensive legal
zoom prices just makes sense too.
Time consuming.
It just takes 20 minutes and legal zoom
can guide you through from start to
finish.
The service was developed by some of
the best legal minds in the country and
they make it painless for you to get
the legal help you need. In fact,
helping people get legally protected
has been their mission for the past 13
years during the national make a will
month get special pricings on wills and
living trusts by entering bur bur are
in the referral box at checkout. Again,
that discount code is bur bur God
forbid something happens to you,
but do you really want to add to the pain?
Is that dragging the swing set out of the
backyard and given it to somebody else
down the street? Some bankers kid. All
right. I know that was a weird example,
but somewhere in there that made sense.
Anyways, it's national. Make a will month,
so don't wait. Protect your family.
Protect your future@legalzoom.com today,
legal zoom was developed by top attorneys
to provide self help services at your
specific direction,
but they are not a law firm.
Legal help is furnished through a vetted
independent attorneys legal zoom.com
discount code Burb, B. U. R. R.
Did you ever try an instrument
when growing up? No, I didn't.
I'm not musical at all. I used to draw.
I want it to be an artist. I would draw,
like I was obsessed with kiss
or draw pictures of kiss.
I could never draw hands.
That's always their thing.
My hands were terrible.
So every couch is do the
three finger thing. No, I put
the hands behind the back.
I really would. Everyone had hands behind
the back. I couldn't, I could not grasp.
That's uh, that's what makes an
artist, if you can draw hands,
you could probably draw
anything in the world,
hands in and tried to ruin someone's hand.
It's fucking hard.
I think the face as hard. Yeah.
It can be, but I can, I can,
I could work out at face. I could do,
I would go, it would be a little off.
You know what I mean? Like it was, it
was like rocky Dennis issue sometimes,
but at least it was a face
bell palsy. Yeah. Yeah.
No, it's all right. I always, when
I, when I tried drawing, I just,
I just remember was everybody
was always jacked. Whoever.
I like the one body type I could draw
would be like fucking jacked and everybody
had the same God damn
nose. But uh, I dunno, I,
there's actually a show out here then
I'm doing coming up where there's a live
band and it's, you know,
I want to do this show.
It's fucking cool where it's like you
go out and you'd just sort of riff about
music and that type of thing.
And then when, uh, when,
when you're done with the set,
you then go and jam with the
band however you want to do it.
You can sing a song and they'll learn the
song beforehand or whatever instrument
you play that your idea or someone
is, no, no, no. This is, uh,
somebody else's idea out.
I hope I didn't say that and everybody's
going to steal the idea of what it's
fucking and I'm going to
be doing it coming up, man.
It's going to be fun as shit though.
Well, you have balls to do that.
That I would scare me. Uh, yeah, but
what I've learned is, I don't mean, yeah,
like I got balls.
What I've learned is that they,
that comes a point when you get
something down, anywhere in life,
you got a gig down.
If you don't keep learning,
you don't keep pushing yourself to try to
be like, all right, whatever I'm doing,
how do I get better at this? I always
equate it to like, I dunno basketball,
some resentment, I don't fucking
play it. But like, you know,
he always goes to his right. Then
you've got to learn to go to your left.
He sucks on defense. I've got to get
better at defense. It's that whole thing.
Like I read this whole, they had
this great magazine out about Jordan,
how we just kept working and working
and working and working and working and
like,
you can literally read the
article and not be a Jordan,
but just apply that in work
and work and work and work.
And so for me,
um,
I'm really comfortable being a standup,
but I'm not comfortable playing drums
necessarily out in public or whatever.
So over the years when every
time I get a chance to sit in,
I would sit in and just go through,
you know,
it's just like you go back to being an
open mic or I think there's like an ego
thing that's involved at once.
You're good at something and
people know you're good, you're,
you're embarrassed to kind of
stink at something a little
bit. So you're like, oh,
I don't want to do that. It takes
like, I dunno, it's, it's a,
it's a balance of the balls to try it
and then also still be fucking around.
It'd be like, listen guys, I know I'm not
a professional drummer or whatever, so
we can handle the bombing on something
like that because it's comma,
you kind of learner.
I like,
I know how to be funny if I'm sucking
at something or I know how to own it,
right? Like if you own
something so completely, people
kind of like, all right,
well what are you going to write?
You know,
he's owning that he's not a good
drummer or a singer, so we can't go out,
go out there and you're just,
you're acting like a fucking idiot
and you're having a good time.
Then they don't have to worry.
Like,
like I just don't want the crowd to
at any moment to have that thing like,
oh wait, is he likes series here? Does
he like feel like he should be in a band?
I don't. Okay. For any anybody concerned?
I do not.
You're good actor though, man. You're
a really good actor. I finally,
I finally went through break in bed and
we'd interviewed everyone on that show
and I had never seen it. We had Cranston,
we had fucking, the guy played Hank,
we had the Schuyler, everyone. And then
I finally watched it and you are so good.
It you didn't take me out of it.
Like, you know, I know you so well.
And whenever you see like a close friend
in something and man, I was like, fuck,
that's bill. And then right
into the character. It was
really fucking good though.
I didn't think I'd seen you since.
I finally watched breaking bad.
I am learning to take compliments,
but I will say that show
the way it was done,
all you had to do is memorize what they
say and hit your marks and they handled
the rest of it. They just, it was uh,
I don't know how to equate it.
Pick a great fucking sports team
and you're coming off the bench.
It's like somehow you can end up wearing a
ring, you know? Right, right, right. Yeah.
I mean one of those guys,
that awful white guy dancing,
but Shaq used to make fun of
whenever the Lakers would win it.
Like that's who I was, who I was
on break at bat. But it was uh,
it was fun. And um, you know,
what's the most nervous doing?
Will you,
cause I remember the first time
I saw you with Cranston, uh, you,
I think when you in a car,
no, the first time I, I had a scene
with him, I was so excited cause a dude,
I was a fan of that show from the very
beginning, from the pilot episode.
So I was so invested in the show and,
and couldn't wait for the next season,
so to all of a sudden be on it,
interacting with these fucking characters.
It was,
it was like you got sucked in TV
and then fast forward into time.
Right. So there was this, it was,
I always said I felt like I won a radio
contest or something like, you know,
do you want to play a storm through over
the next star wars and stand next to
Darth Vader?
I always felt that when I was there and
I would have been happy just getting one
of them. And the fact that
they kept bringing me back.
And the fact that, you know,
uh, Vince Gilligan use so many standup
comics to get back to your thing, when,
when, uh, the question did, the first
scene I did with Cranston was, uh,
was after, I'm trying not to ruin it
for anybody because everybody, you know,
all when I've seen it. Right,
right. You know, spoiler
alert, when does that run out?
You know? But, um,
we'd shaken down this guy
for money and he got hurt.
So we had to go talk to the lawyer,
Saul Goodman.
So it was me and Lavelle Crawford,
but that was, he played huge.
I didn't realize that was a
come out for like knew it was
unreal. Yes, she was good. I didn't
realize what you're committing to it.
Right. So we had this little bit
that we were doing at the top,
this whole act of God thing and then
Bryan Cranston character bursts in.
So our thing was we jump up and Sorta
make sure that he's not coming for Saul
and Saul tells us to screw.
And I was so excited that I was actually
going to be in a scene with Mr Wiker is
Mr. White. To me it took everybody,
I don't know how long, like three,
four season for the entire country, but
for die hards like myself, like he was,
you know,
I,
I've never had a guy like a character
that it followed that I was rooting for so
hard and then all of a sudden
he took this fucking turn,
he took this turn where I'm, I, I kind
of felt weird about rooting for him.
And then I was just started watching
going like, dude, what are you doing?
Just turn yourself in, just
stop, blah blah. And it was,
it was like literally watching,
literally watching like someone you loved,
like you knew like a family
member rooting him on and being,
making excuses for him and what's
he supposed to Dota guy. He's sick.
He had given him any fuck he put his
time in, you know, that type of shit.
And then some somewhat, you
know, it, you know, I dunno,
after how many fucking murderers,
it just,
some of the shit that he started
doing the Jesse that it started to,
it started to turn and it was, it just was
unreal to be, you know, I've lucked out.
I really lucked out where I've gotten
to be a part, very small part of some,
some pretty amazing things. Cause my
IMDP pages is a pretty quick read. But,
um, I got to tell you, I like, I've
always liked the shit you've done.
Let's the stuff you did in Spiderman.
I wish,
I wish I could've seen that whole
fucking rent you did. Even though I just,
you know, I don't like him
and he stinks, but you,
you were really in it and they
had you in the back of that truck.
You just look like this New York guy who
was dropping off something and you will
fucking pissed. I know you're going to
shit on your acting, but I loved it.
No, no, no, no.
But I'm going to point out this is why
bill's a good friend and this is why I
love bill because honestly you,
you had a part in what is tremendous.
Like it's one of the
culturally biggest events.
How bad would Keith be trashing us
right now for helping each and Nice for
friends? Keep it keeps problem
is he doesn't know how to
be nice about anything.
Oh, mommy paid by Keith and he
came in with that fucking pee.
He came in with a Dave Chappelle
shirt the other night from, oh no,
he's wearing Chappelle at Radio City
and me and Collin at the table and we're
like, oh, you fucking fat fan
boy. And we just impact him.
And he sat down for five minutes and
he goes, I'm going to change the shirt.
And he got up and he left the comedy
cellar and he came back with a button down
shirt over it.
And that's the second time in my
life I've been able to chase him out.
I remember one time he ran out with
this show was there that night.
I forget what he ran out, that puffy,
white, awful ugly. It looked like, uh,
a bedding shirt that he had
on and I beat him so terrible.
He went and he hung in there for
like two rounds, three rounds,
and then it was just,
and then he stood up and ran out.
And I remember being pissed
being like, you can fucking do that.
I didn't know you could leave here.
I never thought to leave like that
pounding. I took the bus pounding,
which is one of the all time clubs.
You guys literally did a headlining set.
You did 45 minutes on me
when I was going to do that.
Was it? That was it. We were
both going to do it. No, no.
St Ste. Whatever the fuck it was. Estee,
somebody approached the comedy cellar,
these Atlanta brave fans and
they said it was, I'm actually,
no, no, it was the Braves.
And they said, you know,
they were taking a bus from Manhattan
up to Yankee Stadium and they wanted to
hire a comic for the bus ride up.
And at the end of it they were going
to give you a world series ticket.
So we sat there going, Oh man,
that's going to be brutal.
I don't know, blah, blah,
blah, all of that type of shit. And um,
I forget what happened at the law without
me knowing you said, you know what,
I'm not fucking doing that. That's
bullshit. Right. And I didn't know it.
So I agreed to do it.
And then we sat down and we started
trashing each other. And this is,
this is what you started it. I
fucking go, I said this to you.
I made funniest shirt, but blah, blah.
And I was getting you and
everyone was laughing.
And you know that thing at the table,
you're like, oh my God, I'm winning.
I'm winning. I'm finally winning here.
And then as they're all laughing,
you just lean in and you go whatever bus
boy and the whole table's stopped and
went what?
And you said bill burrs going to do
stand up on a bus on the way the and all
fucking chairs turned at me.
That's the fun and doing it all the
killers were there, you Patrice Voss,
Kevin Hart.
Kevin Hart was there,
Keith was there 45 minutes.
I didn't say a word and
just got pounded and then,
and I was still going to do the Gig
because to me that was an easy gig.
All I had to do was shit on
the Yankees the whole way.
Make Fun of fucking New York
and say that Atlanta was better.
Say That I was a red sox fan.
I would have been fucking
shotgun and beers with them.
It would have been a joke,
but I ended up not doing the Gig,
which a lot of people don't know.
I didn't do the Gig because Patrice
and the end of it through you guys were
trashing me so bad,
like strangers were either
laughing or they were going,
ah. I'm trying to think
of some of the grounds.
The trees imitating me.
Oh, Patrice goes, hey,
when they call you out on stage,
he goes,
are you going to come out of the
bathroom where you're gonna walk up?
Those little steps.
I remember all of them.
He had another one where he was,
he was imitating me at the end of
this show and this is a visual.
It's a lot of the explaining. I finish,
I'm in the front, front of the bus. I go,
hey, you guys are great, and then he
imitates me turning around, sitting down,
and then as people are walking by reaching
over my show. Good show. Good Chunk.
Well Hey, thanks a lot. Thanks a lot.
Thanks a lot. Written my shoulder.
They asked you guys if
I was going to use the,
the the bus drivers microphone to do
the show. I going to bring my own dude.
Every joke was just funnier than the
next one and it was never ending.
I took this fucking brutal Pawnee, but
I was still going to do it. I was like,
fuck these guys. I'm a sports fan. I want
to go to the game. I don't give a fuck.
So in the end you guys had all left and
it was just me and Patrice sitting there
and he just goes,
Bill Egos,
you're making enough money
at this point if you want,
if you want to go to the game by a
fucking ticket. All right. He goes,
dude, I will you call me the n
word he said and what? He goes,
I will stand in front of that bus
still.
You don't do that Gig,
do not do that fucking Gig.
And it was the first time I ever thought
of like, you know like self esteem. Yeah.
Like why not just blow the cash and
actually have a little dignity because you
just come into this business doing like
those Jersey turnpike gigs and all that
shit that you don't, you just feel
like I need to learn how to do this.
So I didn't do the Gig and I actually
passed the Gig off to somebody else and I
too had taken such a bad pounding. I
said, listen, I'll never tell anybody.
I'll never tell anybody
who I gave this gig too.
And I think the person who did it
didn't they come in and say who it was?
I believe they tell you when we're done
cause I mean it doesn't matter. No, no,
it's fine. It doesn't matter now. But
I, I, I don't think he would care. No,
I passed it on. Not at all. No, don't
feel bad. That's it. That's it. Many,
many years ago and he'd probably
be love to be associated.
I asked him what it was like any, he told
me later I go, what was it like? He goes,
dude, he goes, it was brutal.
It was brutal. It goes.
But the second was over and I had
that world series ticket dude.
He ran away from those people and
it's hilarious. It was their ticket.
So then you just sort of sat next to them.
So he kind of couldn't leave him.
But uh, yeah, I'll never
forget that. That was,
that was another turning point that I
learned from someone who I started with
was to have self esteem.
Like at some point you can say no
like I'm not, you know what, I'm,
I'm making enough money here in the city.
It wasn't, I was making great money,
but hey, I was making enough money
then if I wanted to blow, I mean,
how much was the world series ticket
for 500 bucks back then we had to sit in
the upper deck to not stand on a bus.
You fucking moron
it yourself. So youth those gigs
teach you to like, like the,
the seller is getting pounded so terribly.
Like I get beaten so badly sometimes you
don't Bobby or Keith and Collin and you
know when they're all attacking you,
there's times where I'm,
I'm a comedian for over 20 years and I
find myself still answering seriously.
Like when they're killing me, I'm like,
well no, that's not exactly what happened.
Like I'm getting beaten up so bad. They
know all the helpless. I'm fucking,
I'm turning into like my girlfriend
when I'm annoyed. Like I,
that's not accurate at all.
It's so it's cleansing though to
get a beating like that. It's, it's,
do you know one of my favorite
ones watching you taking
a beating was that time
when you were on a date in,
Patrice was yelling over at you and
you weren't talking back to him.
And he started and you just started
opening for dice and you were thrilled,
your hero and you guys were out in poetry,
started imitating Deiss,
talking to you in the character during
the day and you was sitting in the corner
trying to ignore him. And Patrice was
all the way across the restaurant.
And he's going, hey Jim,
let's go to the mall.
Oh,
and we will all fucking crying,
laughing.
And you finally had the given to a man.
Like those are the things what
I loved about it. And like,
I love watching your date,
kind of keep hearing the name Jim and
hearing us laughing and silly figuring out
like, is he talking about you and you're
trying to stay in the date for the
excruciating five minutes, Dude.
Fuck. I miss that guy, man.
I remember one time I was, uh, I would,
I would always come in off
the road and not sleep.
I would be dealt with usually dice on
Saturday nights or Sunday morning and fly
home with no sleep.
And I wasn't doing radio and at that
time was just Sunday nights and be loopy
and go on to the seller on no sleep.
And I always had good sets cause that'd
be creative and it'd be overtired and in
we played chess every night there.
I would play with Keith
[inaudible] you were good too, man.
I started little circle. Yeah. But I
mean compare it to a real chess player.
I'm a fucking on the chimp, but I mean,
you know, in our little the knee you Bob.
Yeah. You were like reading the Bobby
Fisher book. You were into it dude. Yeah.
Yeah. I do enjoy him. Um, and I'm quite a
character I was getting, I remember I was,
because Keith was such a shit talker.
Like he's like a,
he's like one of those
fucking bums in the park.
They're like master level players because
they're all homeless and they play for
drinks, they've found for food.
So they're real players. But Kiki,
like you'd move your queen and do
that stupid thing with his fingers.
Like he was sprinkling salt,
sprinkle and salty up. Wow.
Let's see what color panties she get up.
And I would like literally non-Canadian
guy quit touching my fucking police man.
And uh, you to, you got to reexplain
that to the listeners, Keith. Well,
Keith Robinson would do when he
knew he was closing on your queen,
he would reach over and
pick it up and be like, Hey,
what color panties is she wearing?
And set it down like he was just touching,
talking trash. Oh yeah.
It was annoying as shit.
I remember one time Patrice pulled
my chair out after I had lost.
I had lost and are so fucking
over tired and cranky and uh,
he wanted to play Keith,
so he had winters and I lost it.
He was just such a
dismissive pull my chair out.
And those may with you still sitting
in it. I locked. Of course I was.
And he dragged me out and I was so mad.
I went, don't touch my chair. I'm like,
I'm fucking grown man. And that's my
comeback. Don't touch my chair like, oh,
and how long did you get pounded for that?
I was just an awful night and that was a
bad light. I was overtired. I socked him.
Yeah, that was, you know, it
was the worst was the carryover.
The carry over trashing where there was
so much less meat leftover on the bone.
You'd come back the next night and day a
fucking chair guys, you sit down, dude,
don't touch his cherry. Like, oh.
Sometimes I think about those
days and I was just like, it's,
it's fucking hilarious and
it's a goddamn tragedy.
We never sat down and wrote anything.
All we,
we took all of our comedic skills and
just use them to humiliate each other.
Yeah, we just sat there, but it all
worked out. It doesn't, it, it does.
So those moments I think
made every one of us
a better comic,
a thicker skin comic,
because then you're on stage in front
of 10,000 people and getting an unfair
booing. That was when we first started
on k rock. Right. And you had been,
not the XM listeners loved you,
but they,
the k rock was just didn't
know you as well at that point.
Cause it was a new thing and you had
been away and they're booing you and you
pull out this fucking,
one of the great moments of
standup that I've ever witnessed,
which was just turning 10,000
Philadelphia fucking monsters.
And they're the worst crowds in the world.
If they don't like you and you turned
him, you did the impossible. That's a,
that that's like,
I lucked out.
The sports thing, that was enough. Jersey
and New York sports fans, you know,
the Patrick Division and, and uh, one
of the ML, the national league east,
whatever it does, enough mets fans and
hated the Phillies is enough fucking fans.
Everybody hates to fucking fliers,
you know, except for Philly Fan.
So I was able to do that.
But what was funny was I actually,
when I finished that set,
I felt bad cause you had to go
on next and I was like, Oh God,
you don't want a comic burns down
the room. And that was basically,
that was not a, like you can burn down
the room, I feel as the headliner,
but to burn down the room with his,
another guy going up on basically a
showcase night. I was sitting there,
I thought you were going to be mad
at me and it, and you went out,
never addressed what just happened,
went right into your act
and fucking smashed him.
Yeah. I mean again, they knew me
though. He's like the, the, the, the,
the terrestrial crowd knew me so I had to,
you know, it was kind of like, you know,
they were expecting me to come
out, but, uh, I felt the, you know,
that if that show it occurred
six months after that, right.
When that crowd new year, that never
would've happened. That was just,
that was a really weird transition time.
But what you did with that crowd, Emmy,
yeah, it was the sports
knowledge, but it was about,
uh, the ability to pull that out
in front of all those people.
Cause it took a while. They
didn't just start. Yeah.
You know what, I, I had been booed
before a cup. I've got booed, uh,
on a Vegas show. I,
and, and I didn't leave,
but I didn't know the first time you get
booed dude is fucking unreal. It's like,
it's the weirdest experience because you
have exactly what you want, the total,
the total focus of the crowd, but
the exact opposite emotion, right.
I've always compared it to like,
you know,
when they do the reverse echoes on those
Zeppelin things to make it seem like
you're in health. Like the echo
comes first before you've voiced,
it's like sort of the standup version
of that where it's like they're cheering
but they're blowing. It's the
most fucked up thing. And,
and I remember after getting booed,
um,
just fucking walking through the hotel,
going back to my room and
I started thinking about
people in the crowd and it's
like, all right, Bill, you got boo,
but you let, that guy blew you.
You let that woman with that awful dress,
that guy with the big head,
you could at least said that. It was just
so shocking the first time it happened.
And also I, uh, you know,
I did a lot of those, uh,
the uptown rooms as they call them,
the black, the black crowd. Yeah.
So you kinda had to get, you
know, I was in fighting shape,
so it's somehow,
I just remember opie coming through the,
the curtain LP and aunt,
I think he had his glass of red wine and
Opie just came walking through when it
was just like he said, he goes,
I was one for the ages, Bro.
And just came walking out.
And what was funny was you went out and
killed and the second that was done,
that was the end of the show.
And then they brought me back out for
the curtain call and I got booed again.
Saf Clapping,
half booing.
And I remember there was this dude
who ran up to the stage, he was going,
he's screaming, he's going, fuck you.
Fuck you. And I'm going, what? And he's,
he's giving me the finger.
He's going, fuck you. Fuck
you. And I kept going, what?
It's like you giving me the finger.
How do I not know? I just kept going.
I can't do, I literally got them
hopping mad. He was jumping up and down,
screaming, giving me the finger.
I just kept going. I can't,
I kept doing cupping my ear like I
can't hear you. Right. Fuck. You know.
And it just, I just laughed at him and uh,
that was still, that was the end of it.
And uh,
I remember I rode back
with Bobby Kelly and um,
I had a fucking splitting
headache after it and, uh,
I just remember riding
back with Bobby and,
and he was just laughing going,
dude,
do you realize you just told Tanka
hasn't people that go fuck themselves.
And I was dreading it because I was like,
fuck,
I know somebody filmed that cause I
thought when it got on the Internet,
I knew comics would appreciate it,
but I didn't know that.
I didn't know fans would get it if they,
if they would just be like,
oh you got booed, you sucked,
you know, fuck this guy. Hi.
Hi everybody laughing at and shit.
Cause you know, can kind of go,
can kind of go either way,
but whatever I we have for you here.
No, no, no, no, no.
That, that to me was uh,
that was a fascinating thing to watch
because it was legitimately funny stuff.
It wasn't like you were
obnoxious and got the crowd.
Like you were really
pounding them like a comic.
Like that's what was so fun about if
you had just taking your pants off and
waved your cock at them and I got
right. Any idiot can do well, you know,
fucking hilarious though. But that
would have been much better obviously.
But I mean that was,
that was,
that would have been like it's the legend
but the fact that you got them, I saw
a guy do that.
Did you?
I'm not going to say cause I
don't want to get them in trouble,
but I saw when I was doing
late nights at the cellar,
do you remember how they
used to have that water pipe?
They used to hang and this guy used
to go up, he's a fucking mad man.
And he used to fucking hang from that
pipe by one arm and he had this crazy look
on his face.
He looked like Charles Manson,
I'm trying to let you know
who this guy was, right?
So he went on stage and he's
doing his fucking thing.
And like really just one of
these great comics where like,
just the pain of whatever he went
through is right there on the surface of
anybody moves. He, he's
going to cut the head off.
So there was some woman who was all
fucking dressed up or something,
sit in and you know,
she's the kind of 50s and she's not
laughing and he just keeps looking at her
and he just finally just starts like,
isn't that right, mom? Huh Mom, Mommy.
And he got in her face,
they find just goes mom and screamed in
her face and she got like mad and she
goes, uh, she started giving him
shit and he said, like, lady, if you,
he got to the point, it's like,
lady, if you don't shut up,
I'm going to take my dick out and slap
you in the face with it. And she goes,
you don't have the balls. And he
goes, oh, I don't have the balls.
And he starts unzipping his pants.
The crowd is going fucking nuts because
they think he's joking and he fucking
pulled his dick out,
pull his dick out,
and he had it by the shaft and it just
as fucking purple head is coming up and
he made these machine gun noises. I'm
like, take it right in her face, dude.
Fucking place went ballistic.
Fucking ballistic. And he ended
his set there. I hope so. Yeah.
And Wanda, who is hosting at the
time up and coming, Wanda Sykes,
I think she was the host fucking
outro to them and then brought me up.
Was it wonder, wonder hosted one of
the fucked up ones? I can't remember,
so brings me up and I had to go on after
him and I was still new to New York and
I was, I was already going to bomb and he
took his dick out and shook it and this
fucking woman's face and dude,
I can't even tell you how hard
I ate it and I was too green.
I didn't know to be like, just
riff about the guy. Yeah, that was,
I went up and tried to do my act. I went
up and I immediately went up in like,
gee, it's been raining a lot here in New
York City. It just completely flat lines.
It's like walking into a party and not
acknowledging what's happening. Yeah,
that was awful. I think I know who you
mean, man. Yeah, yeah. There you go.
Well, listen, we're a, we're a
little over an hour and do it.
I can't tell you how excited I am.
Thank you,
bill to to see it and once again promoted.
It's going to be this Wednesday,
July 23rd is the premiere episode with
Dana White and Mike Tyson are my guests
and a, I think people will like it.
I'm actually really happy with it,
which is rare.
I'm as excited to see the monologue as I
am just to see a guy like you because I
always wondered, I always
wondered like, you know, you have,
it'd be like doing a bit
and you just think, man,
that'd be a great monologue joke because
it's topical. Like say your at your,
your clippers guy stuff, you
know, which I haven't seen,
which I know is going to be
fucking great. But like, uh, I,
I can't imagine like seeing that kind
of thing rather than just being like the
safe, right. Sort of a,
it looks like there's going to be
two empty seats court side, no,
the night and the clippers. Right. I
mean some of them, some of them on.
I was just like, are you even fucking try?
And, um, anyways, that's the special uh,
podcasts here with Jim Norton.
Dude,
I'm glad I finally was able to
get you on this. I appreciate it.
I'll see you up in Montreal
and when trying to drag my
a hungover ass out of bed
and come down and do the uh, the
now opion Jimmy show. Yes. So yeah,
I'm doing the keynote speech too,
so it should be a real gentleman's affair.
Oh you are?
I know you're getting the award this
year for a colleague of the year for
hanging in there long enough to get 100.
Man. You've had a great year and it's a
dessert thing. If I see conduct, I
don't like getting shit like that.
I'm not just saying that
because you're my friend.
You're a great comic and when
you see a guy you admire,
you know it's like [inaudible].
The thing is people like,
I don't suck each other's Dicks,
but it's like I don't get to tell my
friends like, you know what I mean?
Like hey man,
I love what you said.
You don't get to tell your friends that
would just, we'd use to each other.
You know what I'm saying?
I just like doing festivals because
I finally get to see you guys.
Cause once we all start, we all moved
up the same time, you know, hosting,
featuring and headlining. So you never
get to work on the road with the tablet.
But when we will all do in spots in the
city, you could kind of watch those.
Another thing man,
when we used to go downstairs,
when someone would be on stage and you
just stare at him. Kevin Hart. Yeah.
And tried to take that confidence and
Kevin, Kevin didn't back down. Nope.
He took it and he was very new to
he, we would walk to me, you, Patrice,
Keith, Bobby, whoever else was around,
just sit there because the seller was
half empty back then and sit in the front
rows. Ah, AH,
or laugh obnoxiously loud it as awful
jokes when you see it on the little
details,
little fucking whore
Florentine would start groans.
There wasn't a greatest skills I've ever,
he would sit in the back,
he would sit in the back of the crowd and
he would turn the crowd on you by like
groaning. He could almost like throw
his voice like, oh come on. Yeah,
come on. And then like it was contagious
and then there'll be like three people.
Ah.
Anyway,
just get it going.
We ruined bosses night one night of
Caroline's cause the curtain was drawn.
It was a Sunday night.
Jim's not one side of the curtain and I'm
on the other and just doing the groans
in Stereo. Aw Man. It was Florentines
were the ones who conceptualize that.
And I'll never forget Voss
for 45 minutes on stage,
just being combative with you.
Like what the fuck did you guys want from,
but you know how I fucking ornery,
he is fucking dope. So yeah.
Why did we do that to each other?
It's fine. Why didn't we support you?
And I'm just, we never,
never support each other.
We have a vos and Patrice gotten as some
huge fight down in Carolina cause he,
he was actually opening for portrays.
Then Patrice trashed his CD so bad.
The brought it up on
stage and he ripped it,
ripped the cover and half and
then broke it and he was trashing.
It's so bad in the crowd.
Laugh so hard that Voss got mad for real
and it was one of the, you know, we've,
we've had a zillion real arguments and
then two days later you don't give a fuck.
And it was just like, why would
you do that? Nene? Patrice
real argument. We were doing
the column Quinn, Sean NBC.
I was trying to get something
through standards and practices.
He was just being Patrice La.
He just give me a hard time with this
woman and I'm like, dude, shut up like it,
you know, and we stopped. I'm like,
you know, I know you're a comedian.
You don't have to prove it. I'm fucking
doing it. This is work. You know,
I was trying to get like literally a piece
of material through and we had like a
real argument over it and Keith
at the fucking play, you know. Oh,
the uh, the arbiter dude,
I had a real fucking item one that
became a classic because of the fucking
Internet. I had that huge one with him
over this stupid fucking man couch show.
I'm on your show on the opiate.
Anthony,
shall we like Patrice called up,
told his man cal thing trashed me.
And then I called up
Monday to defend myself.
And of course somebody on the
show put fucking Patrice on hold.
They just put the two dogs in the
ring, you know, I vaguely remember,
I don't even know if
[inaudible] was a fucking, like,
we were pissed at each other for
like, you know what? It was funny,
but what broke the ice I think was that,
uh,
was that Philly rent the Philly rant.
We finally started talking to each other.
We had talked to him like,
you know, three, four months,
which wasn't hard because we
weren't seeing each other too much.
We would kind of this pissed and um,
when, if you watch the Philly rant
as a time where I look over the Dj,
the Dj going through, why you
yelling out shit, you fucking me up.
I vaguely remember doing that.
But what actually was was
Patrice was trying to help me.
He yelled out invincible,
which would have been a great
one to bring up about Philly,
which was about a guy who was playing it,
was working in a bar,
tries out for the eagles.
Not only does he get a tryout,
he makes the fucking
team and has an impact.
Like I could've just gone off on
how bad the eagle sucked. Um, and I,
I, he, he, you know,
he threw that out there like gut past
our stupid acting like a couple bitches
not talking to each other, saw me in
trouble and fucking threw that out there.
And then when I came off stage, he
just started talking like, you know,
one of the few times he ever threw me a
compliment. Right. Um, and then you know,
that we were cool after that.
It was just like a fucking,
I dunno that Jesus Christ,
whatever. We got a lot of stories
this point. Yeah. It's nice though.
I like it though. I like a, you know,
like musicians hear
musicians talk and I'm like,
that must have been fun to be a part
of that. But then I realized like, Hey,
I'm a part of a pretty cool group of
people, just comedians who I like.
And it's like, I never get to
watch. I don't watch David Terrell.
I don't watch you if you're on,
I don't want to watch standups
to tells latest special.
Oh my God was it won't watch it.
I love Dave.
We were doing co headlining
gigs and he would walk on stage,
literally like a fucking,
like a gnome.
He's carrying a plastic bag with things
and then it's like he's losing his mind
every once in a while because I would
always make him go on last and I'm like,
look dude, I'll take less money.
I don't fit the antisocial. Oh No.
This was just me and Dave doing okay.
And uh, Jesus, what a fucking show.
It was a good show,
but then we would refer at the end.
Like I would come on stage with him and
we were just doing like 15 to 20 minutes
playing with the audience. And that was
fun. Yeah, we had a good time. He's great.
But watching him, like even for the
couple of minutes when I came back,
he would always throw out one or two that
would just make me fucking hate being
a comedian. Like, God, I'll
never, he just did one dumb line.
They give a bid on mushrooms or you're
so high and you think you're having a
pillow fight, but then you realize
you're holding a live baby.
I'm like, I just wish I
thought of that. That's one,
I don't remember how we set it up,
but the Olympics were going on in,
somebody's doing the luge
had died that day. And, and,
and he went on stage and said
something to the effect that I think,
I think it's very fitting that the
Olympics started with the sacrifice.
I can't even do how we did
it, but he did it, you know,
when he talks like low and he just sort
of vaguely threw it out there and just
to see if the crowd even got it.
And it was just like, oh my God,
it's so fucking so it,
it's such a smart joke going back to
the original Olympics and like that time
where I dunno if though they had sex, I
don't even fucking know. It's just, yeah,
he's one of those guys. He, but he's a
guy that I will watch because there's,
there's him and Harlan Williams are
two guys. The way they do this shit,
it's just like,
there's no way I'm going to,
there's going to be no overlap the way,
like, Carlin, we just comes up. Hey,
what are you saying? They're
pig in a blanket. What are your,
what are you doing there buddy? Huh?
What are you doing? Their sport.
They just kind of goes off on these crazy,
I don't even know what he's doing.
Absolutely fucking destroys that. Last
time I was at Harlan, I said that to him.
I go, nobody in your career has ever
walked up to you going, Hey Harlan.
I kind of have a kind of got a joke
like that, you know? So anyways,
I got my dog downstairs, I
gotta I gotta go. Uh, thank
you for go get it. Yeah, man.
Um, uh, it's so funny. So used to
doing the fucking show. He said,
thank you for coming. Oh, actually
I did come over to your hotel room.
I thought it was like, okay.
Well I appreciate it though.
Thank you for coming on the podcast.
I'm glad we were able to, uh,
to finally knock one of these out.
And uh, like he said, a Wednesday,
July 23rd. What's the,
what's the website? vice.com.
It'll be easy to find vice.com checkout
Jim Norton's new show called the Jim
Norton Show, the gym. Know Jesus.
That's clever. Thanks bill. All right,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll see you on Monday.